the family of a palestinian-american
journalist shot to death while covering
violence in the west bank is unhappy the
president will not meet with them in
israel shireen abu aklay of al jazeera
tv was a well-known correspondent in the
region and her killing in may was
roundly condemned a u.s investigation
found the bullet that killed her likely
was fired by an israeli soldier ian lee
spoke with a family member and we want
to warn you the video you're about to
see is very difficult to watch
cameras captured shireen about clay's
final moments
lying motionless a gunshot wound to the
head
as rescuers dodged bullets to try to
reach her our initial reaction to
shirin's killing was a shock
sadness anger lina abuaclay is shireen's
niece we initially met her four days
after the shooting
who do you blame for this israel
definitely
and they need to be held accountable
she also wants accountability for the
chaos at her aunt's funeral where
israeli police attacked mourners that
the shots that killed abu akley two
months later a u.n investigation blames
israeli forces for the al jazeera
journalist death in the west bank
officials in israel say they have not
reached a definitive conclusion
while a state department investigation
said although israeli gunfire was likely
responsible it found no reason to
believe that this was intentional we
were disappointed that they wouldn't
take this matter seriously and that they
wouldn't hold israel accountable ladies
and gentlemen secretary of state anthony
blinken has invited abua clay's family
to washington but they want to meet
president biden during his current visit
to israel we want him to hear from
our to hear personally our demands our
concerns and our calls for
accountability and justice what does
accountability
look like for you
we aren't only seeking accountability
for
the soldier that killed shireen but the
entire chain of command who gave the
order
lena also wants an fbi investigation
full transparency and for the world to
remember her aunt shirin wasn't just a
journalist she wasn't just a palestinian
she wasn't just an american at the end
of the day shirin was a human being
and her
life is important for cbs morning's ian
lee london